- Congrats though you
just turned 50, right?
- I just turned 50 years old.
- Yes.
That's amazing.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you.
Thank you. I know I...
- So two questions.
- I know I don't look it, I get it.
They say black don't crack,
well Asian don't raisin.
(audience laughs)
That's what they say.
(Kelly laughs)
- I've actually never heard that.
- Really? You've never heard that?
That's on my new album.
- Oh my God.
- Asian don't raisin is
coming out whenever. So yep.
- Oh my God, I've never heard that.
- Really? Okay.
- But it's true and I'm angry about it.
Cause I'm not Asian or black
and I'm just starting to look old.
- You look amazing, what
are you talking about?
- I'm just saying, I'm three
years away from 40, man.
Tell me it's better, right?
It gets cool, right?
40 is gonna be awesome, right?
- You are forever young, whatever.
You know what I mean?
(Kelly laughs)
(audience cheers)
You'll never age.
- Once you turn 50 though,
are you the guy on the
lawn yelling at children?
Are you that guy?
- Well, I'm more-
- Does that happen?
- I'm more of the guy who
just doesn't care anymore.
So, yeah.
- That hit me about 16.
- Yeah, that hit at 16.
Literally, you know you don't care where,
I mean, I know I'm wearing
the suit now I'm looking fly-
- Looking fly.
- But you know you don't care
where everything I wear is
gap shirt, gap jeans, gap jacket.
- It's comfortable.
- Yeah, I'm not even kidding.
This is literally what I wore to work.
These are, I don't know if the camera
can get this right here.
- First of all, great point.
- Thank you. These are
Kirkland brand socks.
(audience laughs)
- Not a sponsor, just a fun?
- Not a sponsor, women's size six.
This is the only thing
that lives and breathes
on my foot toes.
- On my foot toes.
- Yeap.